[Applaudissements]
amis téléspectateurs bonjour vous êtes
sur le plateau dès maintenant l'émission
qui revient toujours avec plaisir et
toujours avec vous sur l'actualité
politique de la semaine vous connaissez
le principe hashtag et maintenant si
vous souhaitez réagir aujourd'hui on a
mis des petits plats dans les grands oui
c'est la dernière de la saison et nous
fallait donc des invités à la hauteur de
l'enjeu pour terminer en beauté et en
intelligence on est avec Roselyne
Bachelot ça va bonjour bonjour merci
d'être là ancienne ministre on peut vous
lire chez plomb vous allez signer le
Livre 682 jours le bal des hypocrites on
est ravi de vous accueillir beauté et
intelligence à côté de vous aussi
Emmanuel Voguet bonjour Emmanuel
communicant président de narrative en
face beauté intelligence Valérie lecab
bonjour président de HK stratégie et
Christophe Bourseiller également beauté
intelligent écrivain et historien vous
avez signé dossier troquis l'homme qui
voulait faire de sa vie une oeuvre d'art
c'est à retrouver aux éditions de la
Table Ronde merci d'être avec nous dans
cette émission on se demandera si
Emmanuel Macron sera prochainement
proclamé empereur des Français on verra
si la légitime de tout dire contre un
polémiste d'extrême droite on se
demandera s'il faut déjà réformer la
réforme des retraites et puis et puis on
s'interrogerait sur le secret d'un
mariage réussi entre les républicains et
la macronie pour l'instant même le
premier rencard est compliqué merci
président Larcher mais d'abord les
écolos radicaux sont-ils des extrémistes
comme les autres cette semaine après
plusieurs mois de menaces le
gouvernement a annoncé la dissolution du
collectif les soulèvements de la terre
dans son viseur notamment des militants
d'ultra gauche qui le week-end dernier
c'était mobilisé contre la liaison
ferroviaire Lyon Turin c'est la toute
première fois que le gouvernement
s'attaque à une organisation écolo
écoutée olive et
ce n'est pas la liberté d'expression ni
la liberté de manifestation qui est en
question ce n'est pas davantage des
idées qui sont sanctionnées c'est le
recours répété à la violence contre des
biens contre des personnes qui a été
renouvelées à plusieurs occasions ces
dernières semaines
défendre ses idées
sensibiliser se mobiliser pour changer
la loi oui mais dans le respect de
l'État de droit pas en sabotant pas en
dégradant pas en appelant voire en
organisant la violence le recours à la
violence n'est pas légitime dans un état
de droit et c'est bien cela qui est
sanctionné Christophe qu'est ce que
c'est que les soulèvements de la terre
dont on parle beaucoup est-ce qu'il y a
une radicalisation du mouvement
écologiste
se trompe dans la mesure où comme son
nom l'indique le collectif les
soulèvements de la terre est un
collectif alors c'est un collectif qui
est issu d'une dynamique elle-même issue
de Notre-Dame-des-Landes de la date de
Notre-Dame-des-Landes et si vous faites
un petit flashback et vous regardez
notre Dame des Landes dès le départ vous
verrez cohabiter des gens qui sont
pacifiques qui veulent faire de la
permaculture qui veulent faire du bio
différents etc etc qu'on pourrait
désigner comme des alternatives et puis
des autonomes qui eux veulent tout
casser qui sont pour la destruction du
capitalisme et voilà mais boire à manger
le problème du collectif c'est que vous
avez déjà passifs et puis des violences
vous voyez ce qui fait que de dissoudre
cet ensemble vague qu'elle collectif n'a
pas grande signification alors pour une
autre raison c'est que les autonomes
dont nous parlons qui sont donc ceux qui
veulent en découdre sont très organisés
ils sont d'ailleurs très structurés et
je dirais même très hiérarchisés mais
ils sont pas en association c'est-à-dire
comment voulez-vous dissoudre des gens
qui n'ont pas de statut associatif ce
sont des bandes et puis j'ai terminé à
une chose très importante pardon mais
sur ce sujet là il faut le dire c'est
que l'histoire de l'extrémisme démontre
que dissoudre un groupe extremis qui ça
ne sert à rien
le porte à quelqu'un on se demande à qui
on va aller le porter quel est là où les
personnes qui vont être destinataires
destinataires de cette affaire mais je
crois que le gouvernement a eu raison de
rappeler que la violence est
inadmissible qui a durcissement dans les
soulève dans le soulèvement de la terre
et dans les soulèvement de la terre et
dans les actions qui sont menées on l'a
vu à Sainte Soline on l'a vu bien
entendu dans les maraîchers de Nantes on
l'a vu on va le voir sans doute encore
dans l'affaire du du tunnel du projet de
voix ferroviaire Lyon-Turin je pense
qu'il s'agit de rappeler à un certain
nombre de gens qui sont certainement des
militants pacifistes qu'ils sont ils se
sont enchaînés des gens peu
recommandables
justifiée et utile aussi parce
qu'effectivement il va falloir trouver
un facteur qui va porter ce message
merde c'est une image mais beaucoup de
choses ont été dites et je suis d'accord
avec les deux effectivement il fallait
montrer un signe parce que c'est pas
acceptable d'attaquer les gendarmes les
forces de l'ordre etc et il fallait
faire quelque chose et en même temps
c'est peut-être pas de la plus grande
utilité en raison de ce qui a très bien
expliqué Christophe c'est la
ramification de cette organisation de
ces organisations et la difficulté à les
toucher mais ce que je voudrais rajouter
et c'est le plus important de l'histoire
je pense c'est que on vit une radicalité
de l'écologie c'est à dire que je pense
que le temps de l'écologie gentil béate
ou en voulait changer les choses on
disait attention etc est en train de
passer pourquoi parce que maintenant il
y a urgence c'est à dire que on est tous
on s'en rend compte tous les jours je
veux dire entre la chaleur les orages
les nouveaux fédéralement climatiques
urgent j'ai dérèglement climatiques je
pense qu'il est là je pense que la
population est l'opinion est en train de
prendre conscience véritablement de ce
qui est en train de se passer fait des
années qu'on nous en parle et là on est
au pied du mur et je pense que la jeune
génération face à ça a juste titre parce
que je les comprends parfaitement sont
prêts à tout parce qu'ils sont prêts à
défendre cette planète pour essayer de
la sauver et donc la radicalisation des
mouvements écologistes et quelque chose
qui selon moi va durer et on va pas
pouvoir dissoudre tout le monde tout le
temps donc trouver les 33 associations
et groupements ont été dissous jamais
jusque là une organisation écologiste
n'avait été visée Emmanuel peu importe
l'urgence écolo il faut dissoudre quand
on en vient à ce degré de radicalité oui
moi je ne crois pas que ça a été fait
pour
avec une volonté d'efficacité c'est un
symbole parce que ça a très bien été dit
c'est un congloméra donc c'est pas en
dissolvant le conglomérat qu'on dit ce
qu'on arrête le conglomérat donc
symboliquement le gouvernement a voulu
dire voilà des manifestations qui se
passent lorsque les manifestations sont
interdites on est dans un état de droit
c'est interdit la violence s'est
interdit la jouer la guérilla urbaine
contre les forces de l'ordre c'est
interdit et et moi je pense qu'il y a
des écologistes pacifiques qui méritent
d'être entendu et qui est et qui ont
tout autant conscience de l'urgence
écologique que les dingos parce que moi
pardon mais j'appelle ça des j'appelle
ça des gens qui qui les violents les
violents qu'on essaye de nous faire
passer de patiner avec ce côté
écologiste alors écologiste on a on a
l'impression on nous ferait passer
presque ces gens-là pour de gentils 68
heures avec des Pataugas qui fument de
qui fument de du hache et et joue de la
guitare non pas donc c'est des voyous
c'est des voyous organisés comme les
Black Blocs sont organisés dans les rues
de Paris et c'est sûrement les mers
alors
il mérite il mérite d'être
poursuivi parce que on est dans un état
de droit on n'est pas dans une
république bananière
on va voir ce tweet que le ministre de
l'Intérieur a publié aucune cause ne
justifie les agissements
particulièrement nombreux et violent
auquel appelle et provoque ce
regroupement et puis je voulais vous
faire écouter Gérald Darmanin c'était au
mois d'octobre dernier il parlait alors
déco terrorisme
cette partie de la manifestation
extrêmement violente relevée
d'activistes une quarantaine de
personnes fiches à l'ultra gauche ont
été repérés dans cette manifestation
avec des modes opératoires qui relèvent
je n'ai pas peur de le dire de
l'écoterisme que nous devons absolument
combattre
qui permettent la dissolution parce que
tout ça est très réglementé la
dissolution administrative d'une
association ce n'est pas le chef qui a
été retenu
le fait de la violence qui est qui est
relevé moi je crois qu'effectivement
c'est très important et surtout on peut
en revenir au fond de l'affaire pour
aller dans dans votre sens est-ce que ça
fait avancer la cause écologiste
moi je suis absolument
oui
ça ne fait ça ne l'a fait pas avancer et
c'est même quelquefois contradictoire
sur une une zone d'exploitation
expérimentale du mode de maraîchage en
les accusant d'agro business alors que
c'est absolument pas le cas
s'opposer à la au transport à améliorer
le fret marchandise sur la ligne
Lyon-Turin enfin il y a des choses où on
se dit sur l'écologie à distance
j'aimerais juste entendre Christophe sur
ce mot des côtés
pour désigner alors les soulèvements de
la terre et puis c'est tous ces
associations en général parce que c'est
pas du terrorisme là il s'agit d'action
violente des hérités des Autonomes des
villes qui sont allés pour beaucoup
d'entre eux s'installer à la campagne et
qui sont à l'origine de la création des
ADDES donc des zones d'autonomie durable
ou d'autonomie défensive à des formes
oui mais ça c'est un des nombreux
acronymes ils en utilisent d'autres
quand ils désignent les ades donc si
vous voulez on est plutôt face à une
génération d'autonomes qui est allé
vivre à la campagne en disant la
campagne finalement c'est peut-être là
qu'on va pouvoir faire démarrer les
soulèvements des soulèvements armés
puisque c'est leur objectif en essayant
d'agglomérer des gens dans ce
soulèvement maintenant ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui c'est de la part de toute
une génération de jeunes gens qui
veulent sauver la planète c'est l'idée
de se dire seul l'activisme paie alors
pour l'instant c'est un activisme qui
est plutôt peu qui se veut entre
guillemets relativement pacifique ça
consiste à aller asperger une toile de
de peinture ça consiste à aller jeter de
la peinture sur la façade des ministères
ça consiste à s'allonger devant des des
automobilistes ou des avions qui
décollent ou à boucher les trous dans
sur les cours de golf de sur les
terrains
SUV mais évidemment c'est pas encore de
l'éco-terroriste mais c'est vrai que
c'est sauf quand on dégonfle les pneus
d'une voiture de médecin qui peut aller
se conduire absolument mais c'est disons
qu'il y a effectivement un risque
d'aggravation et là je suis partage
totalement votre avis c'est à dire qu'on
est effectivement dans quelque chose qui
ça c'est indéniable parce que disait
Valérie on est dans quelque chose qui
est en train de croître Emmanuel sur ce
terme des côtes terrorisme moi je suis
d'accord ni avec le début ni avec la fin
du terme c'est pas des écologistes c'est
des gauchistes voilà qui se patine
d'écologie et c'est aujourd'hui leur
cause et puis demain s'il en faudrait
une s'il en faut une autre ce sera une
autre et puis c'est les retraites à
Paris et puis c'est l'écologie
l'écologie dans le lion Turin donc non
pas les terrorisme bien sûr que non
c'est on est dans un état de droit c'est
pas du terrorisme c'est de la violence
gratuite qui mérite d'être sanctionné
mais mais au-delà de ça moi ce que je
suis entièrement d'accord avec Madame
Bachelot il ne desservent c'est le même
pas qu'il ne servent pas la cause qu'ils
défendent il a des serve parce que ça la
rend parfaitement odieuse ça la rend
parfaitement insupportable alors que
l'urgence on est tous d'accord pour dire
qu'elle est là mais on peut pas se
battre comme ça mettre un bazar pareil
et avoir recours à la violence pour
servir cette en tout cas à gauche les
élus de la ont dénoncé cette dissolution
écoutez
on veut assimiler toutes l'écologie à la
violence pour mieux occulter aussi le
fond des problèmes et moi je ne le
laisserai pas ce gouvernement faire des
écologistes les boucs et mystères de
leur inaction climatique et de tout ce
qui n'arrive plus à justifier puis
absolument contre cette dissolution je
la juge stupide et d'abord il
réalisables puisque les soulèvements de
la terre n'est pas une association c'est
une fédération d'associations c'est un
groupement donc juridiquement ça
n'existe pas afin de Soline la violence
a été provoquée par Monsieur Darmanin
quand vous tirez de votre propre aveu
4000 grenades sur
6000 grenades sur 4000 manifestants
admettaient qu'il y a un problème à
gauche cette dissolution est assimilée à
une atteinte à la liberté d'expression
qu'est-ce que vous en passez Valérie je
pense qu'ils ont totalement tort en fait
le problème de la violence en écologie
pour rebondir c'est qu'elle a deux gros
défauts le premier défaut c'est d'être
violent et c'est inacceptable et vous
avez raison contre-productif mais le le
deuxième défaut c'est de cornemériser
l'écologie c'est à dire que l'écologie
ce n'est pas que contrairement à ce que
veut dire Jean-Luc Mélenchon on a une
tordelier un mouvement d'extrême gauche
c'est quelque chose qui désormais
concerne absolument tout le monde le
problème dans ce pays si vous voulez
c'est que l'État ne réagit que quand il
y a une violence extrême je pense que ce
qui s'est passé à la suite du mouvement
des gilets jaunes quand il a fallu
attendre la prise de l'Arc de Triomphe
pour qu'il y ait de l'argent qu'il soit
débloqué et rester profondément dans les
esprits et c'est ça qui a donné l'idée
que aujourd'hui en France si on n'est
pas violent on obtient on avance vous
allez nous le dire quelle mouche a piqué
Richard Ferrand dans un instant dans une
interview accordée au Figaro l'ancien
président de l'Assemblée nationale est
proche d'Emmanuel Macron dit regretter
que le chef de l'État ne puisse pas se
représenter en 2027 il déclare la chose
suivante à titre personnel je regrette
tout ce qui brille la libre expression
de la souveraineté populaire la
limitation du mandat présidentiel
d'antan le nom cumule des mandats etc
tout cela corset notre vie publique dans
des règles qui limitent le libre choix
des citoyens changeons tout cela en
préservant le bicarrairie mais le
Conseil constitutionnel fin de citation
des propos qui ont évidemment suscité la
polémique mais quelques heures plus tard
Richard Ferrand persiste et signe sur
les ondes de Sud Radio écoutez-le
à ses propos c'est d'une manière
générale je trouve qu'il faut faire
confiance aux électeurs et il faut les
laisser choisir qu'ils veulent quand ils
veulent après tout il y a des villes qui
sont administrées par des maires qui
sont à leur troisième au quatrième
mandat et si c'est ainsi c'est parce que
les électeurs l'ont voulu donc mon
propos ne consistait pas à dire qu'il
fallait changer des règles en vue de
2027 et que d'une manière générale il
fallait permettre à notre démocratie à
mon avis de respirer mieux en laissant
toutes circonstances le dernier mot
électrices aux électeurs quel mot
chapitre Richard Ferrand maladresse ou
balancé deux invités sur ce plateau ne
sont pas d'accord mais alors vraiment
pas du tout d'accord vous allez le voir
d'un côté Emmanuel de l'autre Valérie
vous avez 45 secondes chacun c'est ce
qu'on appelle un duel Emmanuel vous
connaissez vous connaissez ça très bien
vous allez nous dire pourquoi selon vous
et bien c'est une maladresse de la part
de Richard Ferrand c'est une maladresse
parce que quand on a été président de
l'Assemblée nationale on a assez
d'expérience pour savoir que la
Constitution elle peut pas être bouger
parce qu'ils n'ont aucune majorité pour
faire bouger la Constitution que c'est
pas le débat du pays que Emmanuel Macron
concentre contre lui à certains nombre
d'opinions qui fait que personne ne peut
adhérer à cela et puis je rajoute juste
pour la forme que Richard Ferrand sous
sa présidence a fait passer un projet de
loi limitant à demander à consécutifs le
mandat des élus donc quand il nous dit
qu'il a toujours été sur cette position
c'est archi faux ou à moins qu'il se
soit tu et qui les fait passer à
l'époque une loi avec laquelle il
n'était pas d'accord et je vois pas
pourquoi est-ce qu'un maire n'a pas le
droit n'aurait pas le droit de faire
plus de demanda quand ce serait bon pour
le président de la République waouh
quelle expérience du duel c'est parfait
merci manuel Valérie avait des éclairs
dans les yeux quand vous parliez vous
avez nous expliquer en 45 secondes vous
éclaire d'amour c'est pas 45 secondes
pourquoi selon vous il s'agit d'un
ballon d'essai de la part de Richard
Ferrand parce que tout le monde sait que
Richard Ferrand et peut-être la personne
la plus proche ou une des plus proches
du chef de l'État et qu'il défend sa
cause en disant ça la première chose
c'est qu'il redonne une perspective de
durée au chef de l'État on sait que
depuis le premier jour de sa réélection
il est fragilisé par le fait d'avoir ce
terme et donc ça lui redonne de la force
et de la légitimité ça lui redonnerait
la deuxième chose c'est que cette règle
n'a que 15 ans c'est Nicolas Sarkozy en
2008 qu'il a institué ce n'est pas une
règle absolument fondamentale de la
République et la troisième chose c'est
que aujourd'hui et ça essaye de le
pérenniser la seule personne peut être
capable de battre Marine Le Pen en 2027
serait Emmanuel Macron donc ce sont
trois bonnes raisons érosine va nous
trancher tout ça Rosine vous êtes
d'accord et avec S ni un ballon d'essai
c'est une réflexion globale sur la
réforme des institutions dont on qui
habite d'ailleurs un certain nombre de
cercles et je dois dire que tout le
monde peut se retrouver dans cette
proposition de Richard Ferrand qui n'a
pas pour but de d'offrir un troisième
mandat Emmanuel Macron parce qu'il ne
peut lui offrir qu'une troisième
candidature et non pas un troisième
mandat donc tout le monde est d'accord
pour la troisième candidature de
Emmanuel Macron ceux qui veulent le
réélire et ceux qui veulent le battre
parce que finalement ce qui va être
absolument
déceptif pour les opposants Emmanuel
Macron c'est qui ont pourront pas lui
régler son compte en 2027 vous vous
rendez compte la tristesse bien sûr tout
le monde veut que Emmanuel Macron puisse
se représenter je vais vous montrer ce
tweet de Mathilde panneau la présidente
à l'Assemblée nationale elle écrit la
chose suivante et pourquoi pas restaurer
l'Empire avec ma son premier Richard
Ferrand le visage de la dérive
autocratique de la macronie c'est des
inquiétudes qui sont fondées
je crois pas que dans l'état actuel des
choses et dans la conjoncture actuelle
Macron soit le meilleur champion face à
Marine Le Pen il a pu l'être avant la
réforme des retraites mais pardon mais
il a perdu énormément de crédibilité aux
yeux des français et notamment il est
suspecté à tort peut-être de quoi de
démocratique donc il y a un doute il y a
beaucoup d'électeurs de gauche ou
d'extrême gauche qui sont prêts ils sont
à deux doigts du vote révolutionnaire
contre Macron où à l'abstention pour se
débarrasser de Macron donc Macron n'est
plus le champion qu'il était
effectivement dans les débats de l'antre
de Tours face à Marine Le Pen donc en
2027 l'imaginait candidat me paraît
relever de la haute science-fiction et
en plus ça n'a pas grand intérêt par
contre je pense qu'effectivement ce le
système est étrange et je regrette cette
cette réforme qui fait que ces 5 ans
justement je pense que le septennat
avait des qualités l'article 6 de la
Constitution qui nous dit la chose
suivante le président de la République
est élu pour 5 ans au suffrage universel
direct nul ne peut exercer plus de deux
mandats consécutifs c'est une réforme de
Sarkozy c'est une erreur Sarkozy n'a pas
fait que des choses bien et pourquoi
pourquoi il a engagé cette réforme à
l'époque on est en 2010
cette donnée des gages
au public aux citoyens en pensant que ça
va ça va les ça va les comment dirais-je
leur rendre politique plus désirable
c'est comme quand on jette une viande au
lion il faut toujours en jeter une plus
grosse le lion n'est jamais satisfait
alors on a interdit le cumul des mandats
on se rend compte maintenant que c'est
une énorme connerie
aurait de le mandat des des présidents
et puis on se dit ah bah non finalement
on peut pas lui régler son compte à la
fin du deuxième mandat et puis on a
diminué 30% les salaires des ministres
et on se rend compte qu'il y a des gens
qui se disent c'est pas possible on a
instauré à la hatvp qui aboutit à cette
chose magnifique c'est qu'on m'interdit
de reprendre ma chronique de
présentation d'opéra pendant 8 minutes
chaque semaine en disant que je vais
intervenir dans la gestion de
l'audiovisuel public on va se dire un
coup de fusil là donc vous êtes d'accord
avec ce que dirait Charles Ferrand il
faut revenir sur cette réforme
non mais il y a des exemples en
Allemagne et en Angleterre qui sont des
pays tout à fait démocratiques Angela
Merkel est resté 16 ans au pouvoir et
tout le monde à l'époque s'en est
félicité en vantant la stabilité du
régime la longueur etc en revanche j'ai
un petit point de désaccord avec vous si
vous me le permettez je ne pense pas que
une troisième candidature d'Emmanuel
Macron serait FA capable aux oppositions
parce que le en même temps fige la vie
politique française depuis six ans et
empêche la gauche et la droite
traditionnelle de reprendre toute sa
place donc ça pour moi la vraie question
elle est plutôt là elle est pas sur
Emmanuel Macron ou pas Emmanuel Macron
elle est sur le fait que entre les
extrêmes elle pousse elle pousse les
extrêmes oui mais on voit bien que les
on voit bien que les oppositions
traditionnelles n'arrivent pas à émerger
avec cette en même temps
de savoir si j'étais d'accord ou pas
d'accord si je pensais que c'était une
bonne adresse je maintiens je pense que
je suis maladresses mais au-delà de ça
qu'est-ce qui va la question qui est
posée derrière c'est qu'est-ce qui reste
du reste du macronisme est-ce que le
macronisme aboutit à la suite un
président une présidente radicale
d'extrême gauche d'extrême droite et et
le déplacement finalement ce grand bloc
central où on détruit tout autour il
existe plus de PS il existe plus de LR
fait que le déplacement de la de
l'alternance
se pose entre les le bloc central partie
dite gouvernement et les extrêmes et
c'est ça qui est extraordinairement
dangereux et on peut changer la
constitution autant qu'on le veut le la
vision politique d'Emmanuel Macron qui
nous avons dû et qui l'a mené au pouvoir
des 2017 peut avoir comme conséquence de
nous conduire à une présidence radicale
un moment 2027 à un moment à un moment
où ce sera extraordinairement dangereux
autre question quelles sont les secrets
d'un mariage réussi vaste question à
laquelle les républicains n'apportent
pas de réponse eux qui ne veulent tout
simplement pas se marier la semaine
dernière le parti LR a lancé ses états
généraux objectifs relancer la droite
après la séquence des retraites c'est
aussi l'occasion d'écarter la main
tendue par Emmanuel Macron écoutez
l'indépendance et la garantie de notre
légitimité la responsabilité et notre
boussole car pour nous seul l'intérêt de
la France doit guider nos choix
c'est en même temps de gauche et de
droite a été mortifère pour notre
démocratie la vie politique a besoin de
clarté les Français ont besoin de
repères la division ça se fait des deux
côtés vous avez aussi des adhérents qui
ont beaucoup reprocher que on devienne
la béquille de la macronie etc etc et
puis moi je sais ce que les Français
pensent je crois qu'on est dans un
moment qui est tellement trouble que le
fait qu'il y ait des députés les
républicains qui tiennent bon qui
parfois résistent un peu quitte à ce que
nous prenions quelques coups c'est aussi
salutaire pour tous nos concitoyens qui
sont inquiets parce qu'on m'a beaucoup
dit après la réforme des retraites c'est
merci d'avoir tenu bon juste merci
d'avoir tenu bon et ça ça compte bon
c'est parce que pense les Français je
vais vous montrer ce sondage odoxa
backbone consulting pour Le Figaro 86 %
des sympathisants LR veulent une
alliance avec Renaissance le parti
présidentiel 83% des sympathisants
Renaissance veulent une alliance avec
elle il y a quoi il y a une déconnexion
entre les dirigeants de droite et en
macronie et le peuple
qu'on disait tout à l'heure sur la
réforme institutionnelle les
républicains sont persuadés que liquider
Macron leur permettra de vivre comme
avant et qui retrouveront le côté
impérial c'est excessif mais devinateur
de LR dans le paysage politique français
Inno réalise absolument pas qui sont en
perdition et j'ai gardé suffisamment
d'amis à LR pour le voir à travers les
conversations que nous avons et vraiment
j'ai écouté le discours de Gérard
Larcher j'avais l'impression d'être en
Troisième République
enfoncer des portes ouvertes en les
prenant pour des arcs de triomphe c'est
pas possible il y a pas une idée claire
mais c'est peut-être aussi ça qui permet
la survie des républicains ne pas
s'allier ne pas se disent il y a des
états généraux de l'opposition Nathan on
voit maintenant que la réforme
d'Emmanuel Macron sur les retraites est
totalement insuffisante qu'est-ce qui
propose est-ce que ils vont se rallier à
Aurélien Pradier qui vont se rallier à
Valérie Pécresse et surtout les et sur
tous les enjeux ils ont besoin de nous
dire qu'est-ce qui nous vendent là il y
a pas un mot de concret Emmanuel
l'alliance ou la mort peut résumer ça
comme ça c'est certain c'est certain
c'est à dire que s'ils ne trouvent pas
des alliances au-delà de leur camp parce
que leur camps est quand je dis qu'ils
sont loin d'être majoritaires c'est un
12 et féminisme quand on voit le score
de Valérie Pécresse l'alliance ou la
mort bien sûr il y a pas une idée Madame
Bachelot entièrement raison et et il y a
pas une proposition il y a pas une
alliance et ils sont en train de de
prendre un toboggan comme disait un
président que vous avez bien connu dont
on ne remonte pas je vous rappelle quand
même que le Parti socialiste a suivi la
même voix et que de 20% ils ont ils sont
passés à 6 pour descendre à zéro je sais
pas combien et et LR est en train de
prendre le même chemin Christophe il y a
une déconnexion un décalage entre les
Français et les responsables des partis
politiques en général parce que c'est
pas que LR c'est aussi les responsables
de la macronie qui disent bon pour
l'instant on fait pas audience avec elle
on est dans un monde de plus en plus
pluriel or les LR c'est un peu une sorte
de miroir du Parti socialiste ça remonte
à l'UMP et l'idée de l'UMP au départ
c'était fédérer toutes les droites en un
grand parti un peu à l'américaine et
face aux parties républicains on va dire
français à l'époque il y avait une
partie démocrate qui était le Parti
socialiste qui fédérait toutes les
gauches qui étaient omniprésents qui
étaient toutes les régions etc
aujourd'hui tout a changé aujourd'hui le
Parti socialiste a explosé aujourd'hui
la droite elle est en pleine implosion
et aujourd'hui vous pouvez plus faire
tenir sous un même label des gens du
centre droit qui effectivement sont
tentés par un rapprochement avec le
centrisme qui soit macronia ou pas on
parle de centrisme et de l'eau des gens
qui sont droites de la droite droite
dure et qui sont un petit peu tentés
d'aller voir ce qui se passe du côté du
populisme
donc vous avez deux lignes donc comment
voulez-vous que ces gens là cohabitent
longtemps dans le même mouvement donc ce
que je crois qui va se passer c'est que
ce mouvement les républicains est voué à
une éclatement un moment donné et on va
voir effectivement en fonction des
élections présidentielles on va voir se
former des alliances en fonction des
sensibilités des uns et des autres on
imagine pas Valérie Pécresse soutenir
Gémeaux et de mettre tout comme ça
aujourd'hui donc je crois qu'il faut
tenir compte de cette réalité nouvelle
ligne on va écouter l'ancien Premier
ministre Dominique de Villepin que vous
connaissez un peu Rosine je crois de
mais il veut pas qu'il y a dénoncé cette
semaine la dérive des LR écoutez-le et
dit sont en train de sauter et je pense
que sur le plan de la réflexion
stratégique compte tenu du sentiment
d'impuissance qui existe un certain
nombre de responsables politiques on le
sentiment au con y compris à droite
qu'il n'y a pas d'autres solutions que
de monter encore d'un cran quitte à
carrément passer du côté des extrêmes
vous êtes d'accord
en fait le macroniste c'est déjà la
droite d'une certaine façon donc
effectivement les états généraux de LR
ont basculé plus vers la droite parce
qu'ils sont obligés de se démarquer
sinon ils ont pas d'existence mais si
ces étages généraux n'étaient pas
passionnants on peut le dire
pour moi tout ça est très prématuré
parce que les deux candidats à
l'élection présidentielle n'étaient pas
là il y avait ni Laurent Wauquiez ni
Édouard Philippe pourquoi on se demande
d'ailleurs une session parce que c'était
pas l'objet de ces états généraux
l'objet c'était de lancer une
consultation dont leur invoquer va
bientôt s'emparer et qui va être la
possibilité de construire un programme
pour la droite pour l'élection
présidentielle donc je pense qu'il faut
leur laisser ils sont pas en forme ça
c'est sûr ils sont même proches ils ont
une tension très basse mais il faut leur
laisser un peu de temps ils sont en
train d'essayer de se reconstruire là en
fait et là ce qu'on a vu c'est les
prémices de quelque chose alors vous
avez un Édouard Philippe qui est sur le
terrain à bas bruit mais c'est une
politique très payante c'est ce qu'a
fait François Hollande pendant des
années c'est ce qu'avait fait Jacques
Chirac enfin des années il était à 3%
Hollande jusqu'à 9 mois avant l'élection
présidentielle ne l'oublions pas et il
doit Philippe est en train de faire ça
et Laurent Wauquiez va être celui qui va
essayer de construire un programme et de
porter une candidature de droite est-ce
que on a entendu Dominique levain sur
cette ce flou idéologique et cette
dérive que des cris canalisent en tout
cas
je vais plus loin parce que je me
contredis un peu en même temps c'est à
dire moi je pense que LR a quand même
une carte à jouer parce que il y a toute
une partie de la macronie qui va être un
troupeau sans berger et que son berger
et de cette partie centriste qui
correspond à ce que à l'UMP les
républicains c'est-à-dire un parti
conservateur moderne pro-européen enfin
qui est le parti auquel j'ai adhéré
pendant cette année et qui a été mon ADN
et que dans lequel je ne me reconnais
absolument plus maintenant et il y a il
y a toute une partie de l'électorat qui
peut se retrouver autour d'un candidat
Édouard Philippe vient de LR et
Bruno Lemaire aussi vient de elle est
Jean castagne vient de elle il y a il y
a beaucoup de gens qui pourraient
fédérer cette partie modérée des
républicains et cette partie centre
droit de renaissance
à jouer c'est l'un d'entre eux qui a
quelque chose à jouer personnellement
pour fédérer tout ça parce que je pense
que la sclérose en plaques dont est
victime et l'air elle est structurelle
et qu'on en sortira pas donc la question
pour moi par exemple c'est est-ce que
l'un que vous de ce que vous avez cité
Bruno Le Maire Édouard Philippe parvient
à prendre ce leadership et à rassembler
à la fois le centre droit en tous les
cas ce qu'on appelait le
mon père modéré de l'époque avec avec
les macronistes qui sont effectivement
pour la plupart pour la plupart de
droite c'est ça l'enjeu mais si on pense
structure on pense échec parce que la
structure de LR aujourd'hui elle est
entièrement dédiée à un une seule
ambition faire de Laurent Wauquiez son
champion Éric Ciotti et n'est jamais que
le phonet de Laurent Wauquiez à qui on a
demandé d'organiser les choses et
l'organisation chez LR il y a quand même
45 ans 50 ans d'histoire qui nous
précèdent chez Roselyne et qui et qui
montre qu'on sait faire donc pour pour
scléroser les choses et pour verrouiller
le système ils sont j'en suis témoin
parfaitement parfaitement compétent mais
ça ça n'assure pas la victoire
maintenant la comparaison avec François
Hollande je trouve pour d'Édouard
Philippe
de terrain c'est quelque chose qu'il
faut que François Hollande convenons
convenons qu'elle est elle est quand
même la conjonction de deux drames
hôteliers le Sofitel et le Phuket
la capacité
mais mais plus que la capacité à faire
campagne à bas bruit sur le Chirac je
suis d'accord sur le fond le vrai la
vraie ligne de clivage entre LR et la
macronie c'est l'immigration peut-être
si le sujet qui est revenu beaucoup dans
les débats ces dernières semaines ce
changement enfin cette sortie sans le
dire d'être hété européens c'est
difficile à dire puisque les LR sont
divisés sur cette question donc il y a
pas c'est pas possible il y avait un
bloc elle air qui serait aussi la
l'immigration et un bloc Renaissance qui
serait favorable en plus vous voyez bien
que Macron ou en tout cas les
Renaissance évoluent sur cette question
petit à petit se durci George Meloni
était quand même à Paris hier ou
avant-hier enfin il y a il y a ce il y a
quelque chose qui se passe sur cette
question là il y a beaucoup de disques
qui sont en train de sauter aujourd'hui
notamment les digues morales les digues
vertueuses donc c'est vrai qu'à partir
de là on verra ce qui va se passer d'ici
2027 Arlon du corps à présent encore
comme Conseil d'orientation des
retraites cette semaine et comme chaque
année l'institution a publié un rapport
sur nos régimes de pension rapport très
attendu cette année évidemment mais
contrairement à ce qui avait pronostiqué
le gouvernement notre système de
retraite ne devrait pas renouer avec
l'équilibre en 2030 c'était pourtant
l'un des arguments mis en avant pour
justifier le passage à 64 ans peu
importe nous dit Bruno Le Maire la
réforme est d'autant plus justifiée
écoutez-le le même président du Conseil
d'orientation des retraites revient
plusieurs mois plus tard nous dire un
énorme problème de financement des
retraites c'est bien la preuve qu'avec
le président de la République est à
majorité nous avions raison qui dit
n'importe quoi cette réforme des
retraites était indispensable et si nous
n'avions pas eu le courage avec le
président de la République avec après un
ministre avec toute la majorité
d'engager cette réforme des retraites
contrevanzé marée et Dieu sait que
c'était difficile les Français
aujourd'hui sera en droit de dire vous
nous avez menti moi je vais vous montrer
quelques éléments de ce rapport du corps
le déficit des régimes de retraite sur
2024 2030 c'est entre -5 à - 8 milliards
d'euros en 2030 le déficit sera
d'environ 6 milliards d'euros la preuve
qu'on n'est pas allé assez loin je
défonce cette cette idée de six mois
alors mais il suffisait de lire le
rapport du corps mais le problème c'est
que tout le monde parle du rapport du
corps et ne l'a pas lu le précédent
voilà mais déjà on voyait que c'était
pas possible on voyait que les
fondamentaux sur lequel était basé le
rapport du corps et c'est ça où le
gouvernement s'est fait piéger parce que
par exemple le rapport du corps est dans
ses attendus avec un chômage à quatre et
demi pour cent
évidemment il s'était d'autant plus
fondé à mettre ça dans dans la maquette
puisque c'est le gouvernement qui disait
on y sera oh l'extinction du chômage
il y avait aussi dans les attendus la
pro de l'augmentation de la productivité
avec des schémas situés entre 0,7 et 1,2
% donc à virgule 4 % d'augmentation de
la productivité oh non d'un chien la
productivité est devenue négative c'est
pas de bol est-ce que c'est pas quand
même un des aveux pour le gouvernement
vous avez promis on avait pris plus de
déficit en 2030 donc c'est pas un des
aveux c'est ce qu'on dit depuis
longtemps ils ont fait un premier pas
pour faire quand même avaler une partie
de la de la réforme des retraites mais
j'avais dit de toute façon avant 2030 on
sera obligé d'y revenir ils ont fait un
premier pas ce premier pas n'est pas
suffisant mais dire que la réforme il
fallait pas la faire ça c'est quand même
un argument spéciaux parce que dit la
gauche non mais moi je suis d'accord
avec Bruno Le Maire pour dire que cette
réforme était indispensable mais la
vérité c'est que pour essayer de la
faire passer ils ont trop parce que si
on avait gardé l'âge légal à 65 ans qui
était la promesse de campagne d'Emmanuel
Macron et il a lâché et il a lâché à sa
première ministre cette concession avant
même de commencer la négociation ce qui
pour moi était une erreur absolument
fondamentale c'est sûr que on a perdu en
cours de route une partie de
l'efficacité avec les 1200 euros de
minimum vieillesse même si ça ne touche
que 20 000 personnes au fond de
l'histoire avec l'index senior c'est à
dire que tout ce qu'on a donné comme
contrepartie au peuple pour le calmer et
qui n'en servi à rien n'ont servis qu'à
une chose c'est à
ôter de l'efficacité à cette réforme et
il leur a mieux valait y aller un peu
plus fort parce que de toute façon la
colère aurait été la même le résultat
était meilleur dans cette histoire on
n'est pas allé assez loin et en plus on
a mis les Français en colère
personnellement ils ont déshabillé la
réforme de ce qu'elle avait de plus
structurel au départ pour réussir
finalement pour essayer d'avoir un
accord avec LR qui n'ont jamais réussi à
obtenir puisqu'ils ont été obligés de
recourir au 49 trucs et avec la gauche
absolument et s'alliéner une bonne
partie de la population française alors
que quitte à se mettre tout le monde à
dos pardon mais autant y aller
franchement et carrément pourquoi pas
aller jusqu'à proposer vu qu'on a un
problème qui est une population une
démographie positive avec un allongement
de la durée de vie et ben index sont les
retraites sur sur l'espérance de vie et
là le problème sera réglé parce que je
pense je pense que
Macron a mis les Français en colère
parce qu'il a extrêmement mal porté
cette réforme des retraites sur le fond
de la réforme sur la manière assez
personnellement assez compétent pour
déterminer je suis pas un spécialiste je
suis pas un économiste pour déterminer
qu'elle a il fallait qu'elle le sont les
c'est une réforme complexe il y a des
annexes partout dans tous les coins tout
ce que je vois c'est que la façon dont
Macron la porter en négligeant l'écorce
intermédiaires en allant pas à la
rencontre des syndicats modérés qui
pouvaient être ces appuis en négligeant
la gauche modérée en se comportant comme
il l'a fait et finalement en ayant peur
du vote de l'assemblée et en passant par
le 49.3 Macron a s'est mis à dos toute
une population qui s'il avait mieux
expliqué s'il avait été un meilleur
manager aurait peut-être réagi de façon
très différente
à ce niveau là non
aussi là-dedans ce sont les syndicats
parce que vraiment la réforme est passée
ils l'ont combattu elle est passée et
c'est d'une certaine façon Laurent
Berger je ne comprends pas la
sanctification qu'on fait de Laurent
Berger parce que Laurent Berger général
cette sanctification parce que c'était
un homme qui avait défendu la retraite
par point bon
il est fondé à dire on n'a pas on a
abandonné cette retraite par point mais
c'était à lui d'amener ses copains ses
autres les autres syndicalistes à la
réforme par point pourquoi est-ce que
c'était impossible la réforme par point
c'est qu'il n'a confond une convaincu ni
la CGT ni est faux ni celui-là j'ai pas
d'Emmanuel Macron là excusez-moi il faut
quand même rajouter que il y a eu
l'histoire de la chevilleux à 67 ans qui
a été sorti à ce moment-là et qui a
provoqué l'opposition de tout le monde
il faut rajouter oui mais sinon
il fallait qu'il convaincre les les
autres qu'il arrive à avoir France
syndical suffisamment un problème de
méthode ce que disait Christophe chez
Manuel Macron on se rend compte que
penser n'importe comment pour toujours
des satisfactions immédiates à terme
quand les choses se tranchent il vous
faut supporter l'insupportable disons
par terre
mais il s'est passé exactement la même
chose avec Nicolas Sarkozy on était sur
63 ans dans la réforme Fillon je me
souviens parce que je faisais partie des
4 ministres qui étaient dans le cul à
tueur qui s'occupait de cette affaire et
Nicolas a dit ah non non pour amadouer
les les gens on va passer à 62 ans
il y aurait eu la même les mêmes
embardées de manifestations avec 63 ans
à chaque fois on donne un bout de
Barback au lion le lion vous bouffe la
barbaque et il est aussi Emmanuel le
problème c'est que le lion s'est fait
bouffer la pâte avant parce que il y a
une grosse grosse différence si vous me
permettez avec les épisodes que vous que
vous décrivez c'est que là Macron sait
qu'il pas de majorité
et on oublie ça c'est à dire que aller
sur des réformes aussi structurelles
aussi profondes aussi clivante avec
aucune majorité à l'Assemblée nationale
c'est c'est presque perdu d'avance enfin
elle est pas fallu faire cette réforme
elle arrive trop tard il aurait mieux
fait l'affaire le mieux fait de la faire
lors du premier mandat où il avait une
majorité pléthorique il se serait aligné
tout le monde mais il y avait pas de
problème de vote de la réforme à
l'Assemblée là là comme on voulait vous
y arriver avec avec le peu de majorité
de crise énergétique alors qu'il y avait
le spectre de la guerre en Ukraine il a
vraiment une inflation
et l'inflation il aurait surtout dû le
faire au mois de septembre comme il
voulait le faire au départ et j'avais
défendu ce point ici même sur je crois
parce que parce que ça serait passé plus
facilement ils ont tellement tergiverser
de la CGT au rapport du corps donc qui
dit que ce rapport confirme les
mensonges sur la réforme des retraites
une fois de plus c'est contrairement au
discours catastrophique du gouvernement
le corps montre que le système de
dépenses est parfaitement sous contrôle
un léger difficile de 0,2 % du PIB en
2030 c'est l'épaisseur du trait il y
avait donc pas urgence selon la CGT à
réformé nos retraites et puis je voulais
vous faire écouter aussi Fabien Roussel
le secrétaire national du PCF qui a
réagi au nouveau rapport du corps le
corps le Conseil d'orientation des
retraites se base toujours sur des
projections ou les salaires n'augmentent
pas en fonction de l'inflation ou il n'y
a pas un taux d'emploi de le plein
d'emploi c'est-à-dire zéro chômeur dans
notre pays avec un taux de chômage qui
restait levé donc projections d'une
France appauvrie d'une pauvre France
alors que nous nous travaillons sur une
France riche donc ça fait des
projections où il y aura un déficit ils
sont dans la même matrice économique de
de précarité du travail de bas salaire
et compagnie j'aimerais qu'on parle du
corps la mutilité du corps de conseil de
rotation il est censé éclairer le débat
il y en a l'impression qu'il a fait du
bazar une institution qui est une
institution de dialogue noyauté par les
syndicats le corps le corps mais bien
sûr il fait ça de regarder la
composition du corps donc son genou
et donc on n'a pas vraiment
une réunion d'experts donc ils est
baptisent des scénarios là il y avait
deux matrices avec ce qu'on appelle
l'effort de l'État constant et de
l'autre côté l'équilibre permanent
et donc chacun est à travers ces deux
matrices on faisait varier un certain
nombre de constantes pour faire ces
scénarios et finalement chacun a pris
dans ce rapport du corps ce qui
l'arrangeait et c'est ça qui est
absolument absolument des avis objectif
il a été créé sous josphinx
peut-être assez intéressant dans ce
rapport qui est effectivement vous
l'avez très bien dit et basé sur des des
hypothèses qui sont complètement
sur enfin il y a plusieurs hypothèses
leur scénario
le chômage incompressible en France il
est assis 7 on n'est jamais réussi à
descendre à 4,5 de chômage en France
donc il y a des raisonnements qui
tiennent pas la route mais quand on
regarde à l'intérieur ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'ils disent que le
régime privé vont être positifs et que
ceux qui sont déficitaires vont être les
régimes plutôt publics et ça je trouve
que ce sont des enseignements qui ont
plus d'intérêt auxquels on devrait
s'intéressant par exemple les cadres
vous savez très bien que l'agir Carco
qui concernait un cadre est très très
bénéficiaire je pense que il faudrait
qu'on rentre plus par sectorisation dans
de la dentelle et dans des choses plus
intéressantes que cette vision globale
en fait non ils sont à 63 ans depuis
longtemps et ben non ils vont passer je
sais pas combien mais ils gèrent très
bien les caisses mais ça je trouve que
ça serait plus intéressant de prendre ce
qu'effectivement s'il y a un déficit des
retraites publics ça va être un problème
donc il faut s'attaquer à ce problème là
mais regardons les choses de cette façon
là parce que de toute façon les
hypothèses ne tiennent pas la route un
responsable de la CGT veut dire petit
dire cela en toute impunité nous sommes
mercredi dans un train en direction de
Limoges responsable syndical du nom de
Frédéric tronche croise Éric Zemmour en
route pour une séance de dédicace il
demande aux polémiste d'extrême droite
s'il prend le train pour Auschwitz la
référence au camp qu'on sera
concentration est une allusion à la
confession juive derrière les propos
sont rapportés par l'entourage de
l'ancien candidat à la présidentielle et
relayée par nos confrères du Figaro le
militant a été interpellé par la police
après ce voyage en train une enquête
pour un jour publique à caractère racial
et religieux a été ouverte dans cette
enquête la police dispose également
d'une capture d'écran qu'on va voir
capture d'écran de la page Facebook du
syndicaliste juste avant son
interpellation il a écrit la chose
suivante
dans mon train je vérifie si le train va
bien à Limoges peur qu'il aille en
Pologne Emmanuel c'est une affaire
d'antisémitisme ça fait pas de doute
pour moi ça fait pas de doute il y a
je trouve ça un support ce qui est plus
insupportable même que la bêtise de de
ce militant c'est c'est la réaction de
la secrétaire général de la CGT
le défendre et pour moi l'antisémitisme
quand il est de droite on le condam
immédiatement et c'est bien normal et
quand il est de gauche on devrait le
condamner avec la même avec la même
force la même rapidité et le oui le sans
eau tiens sans aucune acceptation de
quoi que ce soit et c'est pas parce
qu'on est CGT c'est pas parce qu'on est
de gauche que on a le droit de tenir des
propos pareil il y a un espèce de forme
de point Goldwing comme ça ou
immédiatement à leurs Zemmour et
d'extrême droite mais il est juif donc
et puis il tient à propos qui lui aussi
sont sont vraiment très très à la limite
pour moi voilà l'antisémitisme direct ou
indirect larvée ou pas larvé de gauche
ou de droite et condamnable fin de
l'histoire
responsable ce qui peut rester en poste
un responsable de la CGT qui a ce genre
de propos envers un responsable
politique alors peu importe la couleur
politique je pense qu'il a été au
contact de monsieur Zemmour
dans le train il y a une sorte de
déontologie de l'accueil quoi qui est
dans le passager dans le train le
personnel de la SNCF à une obligation
d'accueil de respect et de neutralité on
règle pas ses comptes dans un train il y
a des lieux pour le faire et des
réunions pour le faire donc il y a une
faute au-delà de l'antisémitisme il y a
une faute professionnelle manifeste et
je ne comprends pas qu'un une personne
comme ça puisse rester au contact de la
clientèle de la SNCF c'est un voyageur
c'est un
et il va participer au comité d'accueil
d'Éric Zemmour qui va donc signer
en tant que en tant que responsable on
peut évidemment dénoncer une forme
d'antisémitisme inconscient pourquoi pas
bien sûr mais enfin j'ai l'impression
après c'est une question
d'interprétation j'ai l'impression que
ce monsieur qui d'ailleurs s'est mal
comporté parce que on va pas insulter
quelqu'un dans son compartiment
sous prétexte qu'on n'est pas d'accord
avec ces idées ça me paraît on manifeste
peut-être à distance à Limoges mais on
ne fait pas ça mais je pense que ce
monsieur qui est connu pour être un
antifasciste pour être un militant c'est
génétique je pense que il a Frédéric
j'ai l'impression j'ai l'impression
qu'il a oublié ou occulté le fait que
Éric Zemmour est juif et qu'au contraire
il y avait une sorte de nazie qui allait
conduire le train vers les camps
ou Frédéric tronche montrerai Internet
d'une certaine façon j'ai l'impression
qu'il y avait dans l'esprit dans le dans
le discours de ce monsieur cette idée là
alors c'est une grande confusion mentale
c'est d'une énorme maladresse et Sophie
Binet
quand elle va dire oui en fait il a
demandé au contrôleur si c'était le
train de Vichy donc là on est dans
quelque chose après effectivement parce
que vous parlez de Sophie Binet donc là
la secrétaire général de la CGT qui a
réagi sur Twitter avec le tweet suivant
Frédéric tronche militant de la CGT
croiser x Zemmour dans le train pour
Limoges il interroge le contrôleur pour
savoir si le train ne va pas à Vichy
Vichy donc est pas Auschwitz résultat il
en garde à vue depuis 14h30 accusé
d'antisémitisme tout va bien dans un
deuxième tweet elle écrit la chose
suivante PS notre camarade a de graves
problèmes de santé Valérie qu'est-ce que
vous pensez de cette réaction de ce
féminer la jeune responsable de la CGT
je trouve que jusque là elle avait
plutôt un parcours sans erreur et c'est
sa première erreur voilà la première
erreur manifeste elle aurait mieux fait
de s'en passer pour plusieurs raisons la
première c'est qu'elle donne un éco
médiatique cette affaire
d'autant plus importante qu'elle est
intervenue personnellement la deuxième
c'est qu'elle soutient quelqu'un dont on
nous explique que il est dans la plus
grande confusion soit il est dans la
plus grande confusion ce qui n'est pas
très reluisant soit il est dans
l'antisémitisme de gauche ce qui l'est
encore moins donc elle est peut-être
aller un petit peu vitre pour défendre
c'est pas on ne peut pas défendre toutes
les personnes de la CGT et Sophie des
Binet qui vient de la partie cadre et
qui est quand même assez évolué au sein
je veux dire elle a une formation très
très poussée quand même etc jusqu'à
maintenant elle avait eu un langage très
construit et très intelligent je trouve
franchement que c'est une
erreur majeure de sa part et c'est
véritablement dommage peut-être qu'elle
s'est précipité mais il faudrait
supprimer Twitter en fait parce que tous
ces hommes politiques
tous ces hommes politiques qui important
à réagir à l'emporte-pièce sur Twitter
et ben voilà c'est une erreur c'est sa
manifeste grosse erreur
manifeste et on peut pas parce que on
veut fédérer les troupes et montrer à la
première occasion que la nouvelle
secrétaire général est capable de monter
au créneau pour les défendre tout et
n'importe quoi et je veux juste vous
dire chez Christophe que on connaît des
antifas qui sont qui sont antisémites
donc je fais pas le lien parce qu'il est
antifa il serait pas rentable on est là
dans l'interprétation d'un propos à
n'importe qui veut dire c'est que ça
devient convenait ensemble que ça
devient quand même dingue quand il y a
un train qui part pour Limoges qu'il y a
une référence à Auschwitz ou à Vichy ou
à je ne sais pas quoi au motif que au
motif au motif que il y a Éric Zemmour
dont je ne partage absolument aucune
aucune des des valeurs mais mais mais ça
ne justifie pas ça ne justifie pas et et
moi ça me choque tout le monde aurait
hurlé au loup si ça avait été un
militant d'extrême droite qui avait fait
ça et à raison d'ailleurs mais mais là
c'est un militant de la CGT et donc du
coup le débat est permis pour savoir si
c'est pas trop grave mais bien sûr que
c'est grave et bien sûr qu'il doit être
condamné
la liberté d'expression et Zemmour a
droit à la liberté d'expression même si
je ne partage au moins pareil moi pareil
on peut constater d'ailleurs que ce jeu
en incident se multiplie et que une fois
de plus la lutte contre l'antisémitisme
doit être d'actualité plus que jamais
comme chaque semaine les amis on termine
cette émission par un top flop je vous
pose une question simple qui a marqué
l'actualité de la semaine en bien ou en
mal Rosine je vous redonne la parole qui
est votre top cette semaine oh mon top
c'est Victor wombaniyama parce que
franchement le basketteur le basketteur
qui va qui va faire qui va faire du
basket au sport je trouve ce garçon
absolument magnifique par sa filiation
une famille
de vieilles noblesse par sa mère de
vieilles noblesse du centre de la France
et un papa qui vient de la République
démocratique du Congo des parents qui
sont tous à avoir fait du sport et la
belle histoire
c'est le soir puis alors un gamin et un
gamin enfin un jeune équilibré
solide je regarde
sa conférence de presse c'était
magnifique je me disais hum il est
chouette alors par contre vous avez un
vrai flop aussi quel est le flop de la
semaine
c'est-à-dire c'est la prise de la
rédaction en chef du JDD par Geoffroy
Lejeune et là pour moi ça me paraît
évidemment extrêmement difficile parce
que le JDD c'est quand même une
institution c'est le journal on va
on va acheter les croissants de dimanche
matin et on se prend le JDD et un
journal centriste équilibré entre les
différentes les les différentes opinions
et là si la rédaction est conviée à
Geoffroy le jeune qui vient d'être
évincé de valeurs actuelles les plus à
droite que va leurs actuelles là on se
dit quand même que c'est extrêmement
inquiétant Emmanuel veut le top de la
semaine je reste avec Roselyne dans le
sport et pour la dernière sur une note
légère pour moi c'est Killian Mbappe je
vais aller vite j'ai adoré Kylian Mbappe
après le dernier son interview sur la
pelouse après le dernier match je trouve
qu'à 24 ans ce jeune homme à la tête sur
les épaules enfin un footballeur qui
arrive à faire une phrase à peu près
construite et qui nous a et qui nous a
émerveillé émerveillé lors de la Coupe
du monde et ça change avec ce que vous
avez vécu à en Afrique du Sud et puis le
le flop le flop 5 secondes Joe Biden je
pense qu'insulter insulter la Chine
quand on est quand on quand on est les
États-Unis c'est c'est vraiment pas
quelque chose à faire par les temps qui
courent Valérie le top de la semaine le
top c'est le sommet pour le pacte
financier mondial qui est en train de se
taire qui s'est bien de se terminer
pardon à Paris et qui a réuni 40 chefs
d'État pour essayer de sauver la planète
et les étapes du Sud pensant à eux ils
sont les premiers les premières victimes
de du réchauffement climatique et ils
n'ont pas d'argent pour pouvoir lutter
contre donc belle initiative d'avoir
fait ça et fierté que ce soit à Paris le
fleuve c'est le sous-marin je suis
vraiment désespérée déjà
la 5 5 décès c'est vraiment dramatique
et puis les conditions dans lesquelles
tout ça c'est fait avec un sous-marin
pas sécurisé et cette armada de gens qui
se sont mobilisés de façon peut-être un
petit peu importante Christophe même
question le top de la semaine question
finalement vous avez envie dans une
époque de de dystopie de dépression
collective nous annonce l'Apocalypse la
fin des temps et pas la révélation
malheureusement et du coup elle dit que
ça va mieux qu'il y a une embellie que
on va vers des temps meilleurs et
qu'est-ce que c'est agréable de
réhabiliter un jour l'utopie l'extrême
pauvreté était divisée par deux en 30
ans bah oui comme ça fait quand même
plaisir bon flop est un top flop parce
que c'est Elon Musk qui de fait l'éloge
du transhumanisme de l'homme connecté là
c'est une horreur c'est monstrueux cet
abject et donc c'est un flop et en même
temps il défend Twitter et là je suis
désolé mais moi je suis un vol terrien
je suis pour la liberté d'expression des
gens qui ne pensent pas comme moi et
j'irai plus donc je suis pour Twitter et
j'irai encore plus qu'est-ce qu'une
démocratie qui ne laisse pas s'exprimer
les ennemis de la démocratie merci
beaucoup Christophe c'est la fin de
cette immersion merci d'avoir participé
salut à vous de à votre écran c'était la
dernière de la saison vous voulez vous
dire un grand merci pour votre fidélité
vous étiez là au moment de l'élection
présidentielle vous avez été là au
moment de la réforme des retraites et
même du référendum sur les trottinettes
à Paris on a vécu beaucoup de choses
ensemble merci encore vous pouvez nous
retrouver en replay sur notre nouvelle
plateforme public sénat.fr je vous
souhaite d'excellentes vacances d'été
sur public on SIDA on se retrouve très
bientôt bye bye et merci président
Larcher